companies hire candidates based on their
proficiency in hard skills and reject
them because of their incompetence in
applying soft skills
and both of these abilities are highly
valued by employers
according to linkedin's global talent
trends research 92 of talent acquisition
professionals believe soft skills are
just as essential as hard skills when it
comes to recruiting new candidates
this fact itself speaks volumes about
the significance of both these skills in
the workplace so today in this video we
will go on a quest to unleash the
intricacies of both hard skills and soft
skills
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel simply learn
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from us
let's start with what are hard skills
hard skills are nothing but the
technical expertise that you gain
through college education online course
or job training these skills are
completely job specific for example if
you want to become a business manager
you must have a good command over
managerial skills international
legislation and business growth
strategies
similarly if your interests align with
the field of software or web development
then you must have command over skills
such as back-end and front-end
development dbms data structure and any
programming language framework
hard skills are the skill sets that are
examined with the help of technical
assessments during the recruitment
processes these skills are viewed as
bread and butter for the job roles that
companies hire for
hence candidates must possess these
skills in order to get hired
next we will look into what are soft
skills
soft skills refer to various personality
traits such as attitude communication
critical thinking time management
creative abilities etc
soft skills help in capitalizing on your
potential and help you stand out without
appropriate soft skills you cannot put
your hard skills to use in collaborative
working environments
soft skills are crucial for you to
navigate in the working environment to
form peer to peer comradery
maybe that is why companies spend lots
of money training employers for work
ethics and personality development
according to linkedin's research 89
percent of talent acquisition managers
believe that when a new hire doesn't
work out it's because they lack critical
soft skills moreover this survey also
highlights that 57 percent of employers
value soft skills over hard skills when
it comes to hiring new candidates some
examples of soft skills are
communication
empathy
adaptability
critical thinking
teamwork and responsibility
you can hone these skills by yourself
learning and practice here's a video to
help you figure out how you can ace
these valuable skills moving ahead we
will discover how we can accentuate hard
skills in soft skills
first we will look at the ways to
highlight hard skins
your resume is the most appropriate
place to exhibit your technical
expertise hence we suggest you to go
through the job descriptions before
formatting your resume
compare your skill set to the skills
needed for the job and add the skills
that are there to both lists
for example if you are aspiring to
become a software developer then
highlighting command over programming
languages like java python or c plus
along with proper certifications will
give you instant credibility you can
also add details of your internship
certifications and projects to your
resume
recruiters prefer students who have
internship experiences as they seem more
thorough with practical knowledge
during the interviews you can highlight
the projects and real-life incidents
where you solve the problems on your own
use more quantitative examples rather
than vague examples to show your skills
effectively
now let's understand the ways to
highlight soft skills soft skills are
personality traits that are evaluated in
interview rounds
the first move you can make to showcase
them is to greet interviewers firmly
if it's a virtual interview then there
are limitations to communicate with body
language in this case keep the camera at
eye level to maintain virtual eye
contact as you converse
doing this will help you build a good
first impression also emphasize the soft
skills required for the job description
if the job requires you to work a night
shift put flexibility as a skill in the
resume or if the interview is for client
support then focus more on your
communication skills the best way to
prepare for soft skills questions is to
appear for mock interviews you can do so
with the help of tools such as mock ai
by amcat
doing this will help you boost your
confidence and help you prepare your
strategy to ace interview rounds
that's all we have for today i hope this
video is helpful to all of you out there
and i wish you all the very best
thank you for watching this video and
stay tuned for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here